blow me down because it helped to raise  or see like he likes his mama late I  have a feeling he'll go far dear Aunt  Lucy  wife in London has been better than ever  I really feel at home if you had one  wish tonight what would it be  I'd like to get my Aunt Lucy a birthday  present off-road pop-up book of London  the only problem is it's rather  expensive where on earth did you find  this at mr. Gruber's antique shop  [Music]  cheerio  we're rich again afternoon chaps I may  look like a hardened criminal  but I really am innocent you're gonna  clear your name your mother need her  help  Paddington's made such sweet friends I'm  in  what a clever little bit go back to that  box  Paddington looks for the good in all of  us and somehow he finds it if we're kind  and polite the world will be right  Paddington too  [Music]  oh that's not good rated PG  [Music]  you